في قمه العشرين عتاب رئاسيه علني من الصين
لكندا وتهاني اعياد الميلاد اجدد ساحات
الصراع الامريكي الروسي
و25 سؤال مع الفنان احمد مجدي اهلا بكم
في جزيره بالي في اندونيسيا بتنعقد مجريات
قمه مجموعه العشرين واللي مواضيعها
واجتماعاتها وبياناتها كلها ما حط اهتمام
الاعلام حول العالم
ومتصدره الاخبار ايضا والعناوين وطبعا
بيصير على هامش القمه عدد من الاجتماعات
واللقاءات والمؤتمرات وغيرها من اكثر
المقاطع تداولا من القمه خلال ليله امس هو
حديث ما بين الرئيس الصيني
ورئيس الوزراء الكندي جاستن ترودو واللي
ممكن نسميها يعني نوع من انواع العتاب
الرئاسي
مباشر
[موسيقى]
مثل ما شفتوا مشاهدينا امام الكاميرات
وعلى العالم الرئيس الصيني استعان بمترجم
لحتى يعاتب رئيس الوزراء الكندي وحتى يعني
وسائل اعلام وصفه الموضوع باكثر من عتاب
واعتبرته نوع من انواع التوبيخ فرائس
الصيني قالت رودو كيف هيك الي بنتكلم فيه
بيطلع للاعلام مباشره على طول القصه
باختصار انه الصين وكندا اصلا علاقتهم مش
باحسن حالاتها ومن فتره وخلال القمه يوم
الثلاثاء تحديدا التقى الرئيس الصيني
برئيس الحكومه الكنديه لاول مره ومن وقت
لقائهم بالقمه الماضيه في 2019 وبعد
اللقاء الجديد في بالك انتشر في الاعلام
معلومات عن مضمون اللقاء بتقول انه
الزعيمين ناقشوه روسيا لاوكرانيا وكوريا
الشماليه وتغير المناخ ايضا وقالت
المعلومات كمان انه تريدوا اعبر للرئيس
الصيني عن خوفه من تدخل الصين في الانشطه
الداخليه الكنديه وهاي المعلومات كلها
نقلها الاعلام نقل عن مسؤول كندي
هذه تصريحات هي اللي الرئيس الصيني شيء
كان بيعاتب تريده على تسريبها وتردوا مثل
ما شفتوه في الكليب رد عليه لكن الموضوع
ما وقف عندها هذا المقطع فمن بعد تداول
الاعلام له والحديث عنهم متحدثه باسم
الحكومه الصينيه علقت عليه وهاجمه كندا
يعني كونان
مثل برده ما سمعته مشاهدينا المتحدث
الصينيه دفعت عن بلادها قالت احنا ما
بندخل بشؤون غيرنا لا كندا ولا غيرها
وصعدت في نهايه التصريحاتها واتهمت كندا
وترودو تحديدا بالتعالي رئيس الحكومه
الكنديه من جهه هو كمان ما سكت فمع انه رد
على الرئيس الصيني في المواجهه المصوره
فهو رجع سال عن الموضوع في مؤتمر صحفي
بعدها وتعليق وكان خلينا نقول اقل حد من
التصريح الصيني فقال انه ليست كل محادثه
سهله لكن من المهم الغايه انه نستمر في
الدفاع عن الاشياء المهمه للكنديين عموما
باختصار المقطع اللي انتشر والسجال اللي
دار بعده كل التطورات هذه كثار اعتبروها
انعكاس واضح جدا للعلاقات المتوتره اصلا
ما بين الصين وكندا
طبعا وعلى الرغم من انه روسيا ما لها لا
ناقه ولا جمل بكلها المواجهه اللي صارت
الا انه المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريه زخرفه رفضه الا انه يكون الها بكل
عرس زي ما بيقولوا فدخلت هي كمان على الخط
ونشرت على قناتها على تلجرام الفيديو
وعلقت انه والله الصينيين محظوظين لانه
تريدوا على الاقل ما صور وسجل وسر بالكلام
كامل مثل ما عمل مكان خلال محادثه عبر
الانترنت مع بوتن وقالت انه هيك بيتعامل
الناس اللي من غير شرف وكرامه بحسب
تعبيرها زخرفه هون تتلمع طبعا القصه صارت
فيه يوليو الماضي لما كان في محادثات على
الانترنت
و روسيا وقتها تمت فرنسا بتسريب مضمون
اللقاء عن طريق صحفيين دخلوا الاجتماع
لانهم مسؤولين في الوفد وسجلوا اللقاء
ونشروا
اكيد كل يوم لازم يكون في اخبار عن ايلون
ماسك فمن اوائل الاشياء اللي عملها ماسك
لمستحود على تويتر
وكمان لو تذكر وهو حل مجلس الاداره واعلن
نفسه الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه ومن الاخر
يعني هو الكل في الكل ووقتها لما سال في
الموضوع وتم انتقاده قال يا جماعه الموضوع
مؤقت واليوم رجع تاكد هذا الكلام ف خلال
جلسه استماع بخصوص بخصوص عفوا المحاكمه
لها علاقه بشركه ثانيه تسلا لهم ماسك فجر
تصريح مفاجاه وقال انه يا جماعه انا مش
نفسي اكون رئيس تنفيذي لاي الشركه اصلا
وبخصوص تويتر تحديدا قال انه بدور على شخص
اخر يمسك زمام الامور اول بسمه الامور
تستقر
لهم ماسك للعلم هو حاليا الرئيس التنفي
لثلاثه
وظيفه رئاسه تويتر اكيد يعني وظيفه بحلم
فيها كثار من الناس يعني لو فتح ماسك
الباب راح يقدم عليها المئات اذا ما لو ما
كانش الالاف حتى مجرد العمل بشركه مثل
تويتر هي حلم لك كثير من الناس لكن في
ايميل داخليه ماسك لموظفين تويتر
وتسرب للاعلام يمكن يغير وجهه النظر هذه
فا لهم ماسك اللي همم طبعا والرادي صار
طارد الاف الموظفين من تويتر بعد ايميل
الموظفين الحاليين بقول لهم في انه الفتره
الجاي الشغل راح يكون كثير صعب وراح يكون
كثير في شغل وامامهم حلين يا اما العمل
المضاعف او الطرد ماسك في رسالته لموظفين
تويتر حط لينك موظفين واعطاهم مهله لحد
يوم الخميس يعني اليوم يعني لحتى ياخذوا
قرارهم وقال لهم الفتره الجايه الفتره
صعبه بدنا نبني فيها تويتر اقوى واجدد
وهذا راح نطلع عمل مكثف ومضاعف وساعات
طويله فاللي مستعد لهذا الشيء يضغط على
هاي اللينك واللي مش مستعد فا الله معه
وراح ياخذ تعويض راتب ثلاثه شهور
[موسيقى]
العلاقات المتوتره وطبعا اهلا فيكم من
جديد العلاقات المتوتره ما بين امريكا
وروسيا موضوع لا يخفى على احد يعني
اسبابها وتداعياتها وحتى سحاتها كل ما لها
بتتوسع وبتزيد اليوم اكتشفنا ساحه جديده
من ساحه الخلاف الامريكي الروسي والساحه
هي التهنئه باعياد الميلاد وايضا يا جماعه
من مواليد 20 نوفمبر 1942 يعني كمان ثلاث
ايام راح يطبق 80 سنه في روسيا خلال مؤتمر
الصحفي في صحفي سال المتحدث
لو كان بوتن ناوي يبعث لبنت تهنئه بمناسبه
عيد ميلاده وانه يعني مو اي عيد ميلادها
هدول 80 سنه بسكويت رد وقال انه لا بيتوقع
بس المفاجاه مش هون المفاجاه بالتدرير
الاستخدامه المتحدث
بعيد ميلاده لانه يوم السابع من اكتوبر
كان عيد ميلاد بوتن ومو اي عيد ميلاد كمان
كان برضه عيد ميلاد مختلف في وقتها طبق ال
70 سنه
وبعيدن ما همناه فعلى مبدا واحده بواحده
الكريم اعلنها ما راح انها بايظه
بالمناسبه الحديث عن بعيد عن في مقطع
متداول منها مش قمه العشرين لبايدن بيمدح
في عضلات مصور قبل ما يتفاجا بمعلومه ما
كانت على البال ولا على الخاطر
حلوه ههه
[موسيقى]
المراسلين الصحفيين اللي بالميدان تحديدا
ياما بيتعرضوا لمواقف صعبه ومزعجه ممكن
تكون محرجه وحتى مضحكه في بعض الاحيان لكن
الي صار مع هذا المراسل الكيني ما صار من
قبل
فندق
حيوانات
[موسيقى]
وهكذا مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه
تفاعلكم طبعا اتركم الان مع الفقره
الاسبوعيه 25 سؤال وضيف ساره الدندراوي في
هذا الاسبوع هو الفنان المصري احمد مجدي
اشكركم حسن متابعه والى اللقاء
احمد مجدي 25 سؤال لازم تجاوب عليهم بسرعه
من غير تفكير اكثر مكان تشعر فيه بالسعاده
اكثر قاسم مشترك بينك وبين زوجتك
من سنتين
قبل الجيش يعني هي العلاقه كلها كانت اربع
سنين
الشاشه الرمضانيه وفتح الشاشه الاول من
فين جاءت هذه الالقاب اكيد حد يعني
خالص 2015
بحس نفسي اسعد كمخرج
اسوء شيء عملته في مراهقتك
السرقه
اه غني لي اغنيه بتعبر عنه انا توب عن حبك
انا انا ليا في بعدك انا لي اغنيه
[موسيقى]
اللي كانت شغلاني لقيت في اليوجا الامان
همم موضوع نفسك تتناوله في عمل فني
همم اكثر شائع عنك ازعجتك
بالحقيقه انا مش بتاثر قوي بشعات
فعلا في واحده ازعجتني
استغربتها حاجه
ضايقتني
في حاجه كده خالص
المهم بقى طيب كم طولك 189 بعد الناس
بيوصفوك بالغريب دخل في اليوكا والبيئه
والطبيعه ونباتي وبتميل للسينما المستقله
وبتجمع الات موسيقيه قديمه بيزعجك عدم فهم
الناس الميوله
بفتح للناس افوق جديده مع الوقت وكلنا
عندنا حاجات غريبه باشكالنا مختلفه
ااااه ضرني
تتمنى لو كان لك
بصراحه كثير قوي يعني من اول ابيض واسود
قبل ما اتولد
في الغلط بس الحقيقه والممثل اللي جوايا
دائما بيغير يعني بشوف ادوار كثير لاصدقاء
والزملاء في نفس سني لو كنت مكانه كنت
عاملها
عيني في الغلط ليه
بقى العجز زميلك هينبسط همم
باحاول افتكر حاجه بجد كانت كبيره ومهمه
همم
يا ربي كانت حاجه مؤثره قوي همم
باشوف عمر الشريف بيقول انا كان نفسي اكون
في العصر ده بس ده اكثر حاجه والحاجات
بتاعت نجيب محفوظ يعني اي حد بيشتغل على
نجيب محفوظ بحيث ان انا يعني نفسي ابقى
مكانه واسامه انور اوكي يعني بالنسبه لي
في حاجات كثير قوي لما باشوفها فعلا ما
فيش حاجه معينه بس بجد يعني الممثل جواه
غيور شويه
في واحد في قرارات كثير الواحد اخذها غلط
عندكم
ابدا ابدا انا بحب العربيات وبحب
الموتوسيكلات وكده بس يمكن انت عشان بتشيل
الحب للموتوسيكلات في الحته دي بالضبط بس
الحقيقه هو الموتوسيكل دلوقتي هو احلى
حاجه في حياتي يعني السعاده
والمتعه اللي بتجيء لي من الموتوسيكل
بتخليني دايما ابقى حابب ان انا ابقى عليه
طول الوقت
بينفعل جدا ودي كانت الحاجه اللي عايز
امان وانا صغير كان دائما يعني وبي- يعني
لحد لما جبت الموتوسيكل غصب عنه فاستسلم
تعرضت الانتقادات كثيره على مسلسل فرصه
ثانيه وانه العمل ركيك كيف بترد الحقيقه
انا ما جاليش اي انتقادات لهذه لهذه
الدرجه يعني اه ممكن ده يكون حصل وانا
سمعت انه حصل لكن الحقيقه انا كل الفيد
باك اللي جالي كان عظيم جدا الفان دايز
بتاعتي كبرت جدا
والمسلسل بالنسبه لي نجح جدا ونجح في
تحقيق اللي انا كنت كل اللي كنت عايزه منه
يقال انك مهتم بتجسيد شخصيه المخرج الراحل
يوسف شاهين في عمل ليش الحياه هو من اهم
الايقونات السينمائيه اي حد يحلم انه
يعملها ومره اتسالت السؤال ده وقعت بلساني
وقلت ان هي دي الشخصيه الايقونيه الاكثر
يعني ملحه جدا وما عنديش اي تصور دي ممكن
يحصل ازاي بس هي كان مجرد مره وقعت بلساني
وقتها بس هي حقيقه
عمر الشريف بشكل
استثنائي وظهر في لحظه يعني كان صديق
الاسد زبار واستل ادلر وناس مهمه جدا في
السينما يعني في العالم ولكن انا الحقيقه
باشوف انه الشغل الممثل ممكن يشتغل انه
يبقى نجم ممكن يشتغل على انه يبقى ممثل
كويس ممكن يشتغل انه يبقى فنان حقيقي
المشكله ان احنا عايزين نعمل كل حاجه
كممثلين ف- همم لحد لما الواحد يستقر في
انه فعلا المجهول المجهود اللي هو عايز
يعمله هو في انهو اتجاه هيوصل اللي هو
عايزه طيب ليش في تعليقات كثيره على موضوع
ملابس
اشياء غريبه وكذا هو حصلت هي في مره واحده
حصلت مره كبيره بالضبط
يعني فجاه لقيت نفسك ترند بسبب البدله اوي
طيب شيء ما يعرف الناس عنك
[ضحك]
اه مثلا
كنت هاغرق مثلا مره في حياتي يعني
كده وانا كنت بلعب تجديف
دي من اصعب اللحظات اللي في حياتي يعني
وفكر ال- همم يعني كان اول مره اقول كلمه
الحقوني يعني كان همم كنت باسمعها في
الافلام والمصدقهاش بس كانت فعلا تجربه
صعبه جدا يعني ف همم كانت همم
ما وقفتش لا خالص كان بالنسبه لي حاجه
بطل الجمهوريه مثلا على فكره عايز ياخذ
السنه اللي بعديه يعني
اكثر
نفسي اكثر
تسلقيه يعني بدل ما تستري علي همم مش عارف
هو بقى شقي شويه وباحب الباركور وبحب
اتحرك وباخذ حاجات شويه ريسكي ف- اا في
القياده مثلا ما بقولش ده طبعا كثير
البس الخوذه
همم وودنسي سوري انا مركز جدا جدا بصراحه
في شغلي الفتره دي
[موسيقى]